يا ترى شقان الاتهامات كما الرصاص على
حدودهما المشتركه الممتده على اكثر من 900
كيلومتر تجمع بين ايران وافغانستان
دولتان فرقتهما الانهار التي جرت فيهما
على قدر ما وصلت بينهما منذ مئات السنين
مياه اشعلت صراعا كان خفيا منذ عام
1982 لكن الخلاف على تقاسم مياه نهر هلمند
بات جليا
تعلو اصوات المدافع ومعها تؤكد ايران ان
الحدود تحت سيطرتها الكامله لكن لغط تنجر
مع طالبان ادى الى تلك الحوادث وفي كل
الاحوال اكدت طهران ان نزاعها مع كابول لن
يمثل سوى خساره استراتيجيه لكلتيهما
وبينما تحذر حركه طالبان مما اسمته اصطناع
اعذار لشن حرب اشهرت اسلحتها ودباباتها
لينتهي بها الامر بتصعيد لهجه احد
قيادييها الذي قال انه اذا لزم الامر
بامكان طالبان الاستيلاء على ايران في
غضون 24 ساعه
هل من ذاك النهر الذي ينبع من جبال
هندوكوش شمال شرقي افغانستان ويصب في
بحيره هامون الايرانيه يعد اهم مصدر للماء
في البلدين وشريانا اساسيا لمحافظه سيستان
وبروجستان الا ان طالبان اغلقت سد كاجكي
ورفضت منحه طهران حصتها السنويه المقدره ب
820 مليون متر مكعب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات